we've worked on a model of what we are
calling prisons precision medicine which
means medicine based on mechanistic
aspects that the science is bringing
forward in an attempt to predict how the
science is going to change medicine we
made assumptions about how the science
will change and then proceeded to work
through a model that on the basis of
those assumptions how will that affect
the health system other patients will be
affected how the payers and providers
will need to respond and so forth and
the model really is based on I think the
next five to ten years of what will
Obama in the healthcare system it's
relatively complex going to be difficult
to implement a lot of challenges and
risks but i think it's we're all
convinced it's the future of medicine
and therefore the future of the
healthcare systems and i think it will
be quite exciting and no matter what
happens it's clear that this is what's
coming